hello folks welcome to rational science
directly from frankfurt germany
2100 hours over here
and what do we do here well for those of
you who are new
to the channel
uh what we do is a little bit of physics
the only site that really does physics
on the internet
everybody else does irrational
explanations and a bunch of math
whatever they learn from quantum
mechanics and general relativity
and what we also do here is a little bit
of extinction we're saying we're the
last generation of humans on earth
is that possible
so we talk a little bit about extinction
as well now at the end i open up the
floor for questions and comments that
people made since last time
okay so here we go let's get started
with extension first or topics related
to extinction
and in the news we have the following
says the us cracks down on imported
goods made by uyghurs and victims of
forced labor
talking about china
and so uh what it's doing it's um
confiscating or not accepting blocking
whatever you want to call it uh goods
made from china
or coming from china
indirectly apparently these were
vietnamese goods came from vietnam that
apparently were made in china
and so the united states is cracking
down on that
what should we do uh think about that um
i mean
you know
politicians do whatever they want they
can take whatever decisions they want
but it tells you something
and it tells you at least what it tells
me is that
the united states is in trouble
i mean if the united states has to
resort to these
uh measures
uh it seems like uh desperation it seems
like um
they're in some kind of trouble that's
what it tells me for example let me let
me contrast this with
another piece of news that you'll see
around there and that's this that in
saudi arabia
they also are using
forced labor
to
build things
and
the united states doesn't take the same
type of measures against saudi arabia
you know so there's uh like a double
standard here uh it's like you know the
the uh
saudis can do anything they want in fact
uh you had this guy mohammed bin salman
and apparently he killed
this well khashoggi
at uh at an embassy in turkey
and uh he got away with it uh no
no
they're never gonna bring him to trial
or anything you know and the cia has
already determined that yeah he knew
about it he uh
caused that problem he
uh ordered the murder of this guy
khashoggi
and so the question is uh why china is
it because united states is in trouble
economically
and i
hope not
because if the united states is in
trouble then we're all in trouble okay
like i said you know the united states
is the last empire there will not be a
chinese empire and if the united states
is taking these measures against the
empire of china
is because uh it's in a little bit of
trouble
okay
now china does uh
you know have uh this communist regime
it controls the population it doesn't
allow other countries among the united
all the st etc so the united states is a
little worried that it can't get in
there
the way it wants to like in other
countries
and at the same time here's the chinese
catching up with the united states
economically in fact
if things continue as they are now
it is said that maybe in four or five
years
china will be at the same level uh as
united states
economically
possibly even militarity
and so um
is that gonna mean that we're gonna have
a chinese empire the chinese empire is
gonna surpass the american air empire
or is there gonna be a war before that
happens
okay food for thought
uh again
i i don't want to
speculate on the possibility of war but
it is a very likely possibility all you
need is a false flag
to get that rolling right and those are
very common in history
okay and here's another bit of
information that makes you want to think
about you know how well the economy is
uh
in the uh
in the united states especially right
here it is uh this is the note
says uh high demand at food pantries
okay
uh this is just one bit of information
uh talking about
san jose california i used to live in
that area
and food is getting more expensive
hunger that's what they said in this bit
of news feed people that lost their jobs
during the pandemic many still can't
afford food
is this the united states people can't
afford food in the united states
i mean what is this uh we're talking
about a fourth world country here or
what
at the same time food prices are surging
because of the pandemic right uh supply
problems and worker shortages
yeah
some people apparently um
don't want to accept jobs that are
available
i guess they're picking
what jobs they want to have
it's a you could say it's a labor market
maybe quotations on that
because the question is whether salaries
are going to go up and whether the jobs
that are available
are jobs that people want okay but yeah
when you're starving
uh you typically get whatever job you
there is out there and what they're
saying is that they're not using this
word
hunger is there hunger or is this uh
people just
uh taking advantage of the system
i mean you know people accuse the
government of misleading and taking
advantage here we have the other side of
the coin where people take advantage of
laws or
uh
you know
economic measures that are out there
you know they just take advantage of
that and so we got it on both sides
right
and um
here's uh one analysis of that says the
u.s economy entered only 235 000 jobs
the lowest gain since january
economists were expecting 720
000 new hires so less than half okay
that's what they got
and the unemployment dipped
okay it was in 5.4 it's still dipped to
5.2 so people are not looking for jobs
apparently
that's that's what you got to conclude
from this right
it's not that there aren't enough jobs
there are record high 10 million u.s job
openings still 8.4 million americans are
unemployed so it looks like everybody's
just clinging to the benefits
more or less they like the fact that
they're at home
collecting a paycheck and these are some
of the reasons workers aren't returning
you have coveted fears okay child care
needs okay
you have boosted unemployment benefits
people who are making a little more
money now and they say well i'm gonna
hang out a little longer you know before
i get a job
and then uh there's a apparently a
favorable labor market okay jobs are
plentiful wages are rising
but nobody's getting them
nobody's asking for those jobs okay now
all that may stop
uh
when when the uh
these benefits stop is that what it is
uh too much socialism we got to get
people to work uh the
good old capitalist way
uh forced labor you know you're starving
you're forced to work
that sort of thing
okay so keep that in mind um
my issue is whether
the united states is really going to
come out of this
economic uh
problem
okay this situation
that was created apparently by
a bug that's out there okay whether
there's a bug or not is in my opinion is
irrelevant i look at what's happening
you know as far as the what is happening
to the economy okay so that's what i
keep my eyes on
okay um one person says
extinction is almost nothing but a
prediction
ah
well that's why i uh ask people to do
extension 101 before they do extinction
102 extinction 102 human extinction
extinction 101
mass extinction mass extinction only
refers to the past and that's not a
prediction you don't predict the past
except in mathematical physics
they predict the past all the time they
say they predict how the universe got
started
i love that one
they break the original
seed that gave birth to the universe and
this is more or less the same thing you
don't predict the past you don't predict
mass extinction you don't predict how
the dinosaurs die you don't predict how
the
permian uh mammal like reptiles died
okay
uh we don't do prediction uh we don't
predict the past so first you got to
predict the past then you can move on
and predict the future okay please
predict the fact the past okay that's
what we need so you need to tell me
how
animals in the past died
because we're looking at not how man is
going to die we're looking at the
mechanism of a mass extinction okay
and then we're going to extrapolate that
mechanism mechanism not prediction
mechanism we're going to extrapolate the
mechanism to man and say well can man
do anything about that same mechanism
that all the others animals in the past
couldn't do anything about
okay that's the reasoning okay so we're
not talking about uh the future we're
really talking about the past we're
talking about the mechanism when people
focus on when it's going to happen
then we got a problem
we're talking about how
it's going to happen okay and how it's
going to happen has to do with analyzing
mass extinctions that already have
occurred so no it's uh
it's not a prediction and here again i
always say do
extinction 101 which is mass extinction
before you do extinction
102 which is human extinction because
otherwise you're going to get into that
kind of problem you think that you're
predicting something when you're not
you're focusing on
on when it's going to happen you say
it's going to happen the future is going
to happen within my lifetime well that's
different than saying that um
that it's uh that how how it's going to
happen okay
okay um
another question person
uh raised says you are right about
everything except
an extinction of humanity
there will be a large decline in the
world population but not an extinction
okay that will be reserved for the
corrupt governments
the governments will go extinct okay we
have a communist here okay
uh you know
the way it worked um
you know if you read marx okay and
angles
um
they predicted or they wanted really
more than a prediction they recommended
they wanted they thought it would happen
right
that sometime in the future
there would be revolutions
so that workers took over power over the
governments
and then from then on you know uh it
would lead to a world government where
all civilized persons
would finally get together and say okay
we let's have one world government let's
control it let's the workers the people
who produce the goods right
out there let them govern
and then at some point in time we reach
this
uh point where there's anarchy
not anarchy in the sense of you know the
guy with the
molotov
cocktail we're not talking about that
kind of anarchy no we're talking about a
different kind of anarchy we're saying
that
uh the the system of government meaning
no government okay
so it leads to no government uh
the the
train of thought that marx had was first
we have a world government and then that
government itself realizes that there's
no need for it and it ceases to exist
okay
now uh what i criticized today in
retrospect uh you know i've done a lot
of marxism in my life but what i
criticized is that you know marx applied
that to the 19th century which was an
age of primarily agriculture
gradually converting in those days into
manufacturing so when he analyzed uh
all this uh communism stuff he did it
all in the context of
manufacturing of industry blue collar
workers that's what he
i'm black
well no dark blue sorry i'm still a blue
collar um
he he was thinking of blue-collar
workers those were the ones who were
gonna take over the government because
they they were the ones who were
producing the goods
what he didn't predict was that
manufacturing was going to go away
completely almost completely okay
it's been replaced by services
service is a totally different kind of
economy that has nothing at all to do
with manufacturing or agriculture or
hunter gathering
so we went from hunter gathering which
we did most of our existence we went did
a little bit of 10 000 years of a little
more a little less of agriculture then
we did industry we did manufacturing and
now we've moved into services
and the issue is what's next
are we going to be doing services for
the next gazillion years
okay so uh marx did not predict
services
and uh obviously he couldn't have known
that we would have invented internet and
all that stuff today we don't even have
regular services you know like hand
services what we have is internet
services
internet services is a higher level of
abstraction
you know we have bitcoin we have all
these uh people on youtube like me
just providing a service
okay
so uh think about that all the jobs that
we're creating today or a lot of them
are internet uh stuff just very very
abstract stuff
learning teaching
uh
girls uh showing whatever they have
those are services today someone singing
you know
great that's a great production
productive economy
okay uh
fallout says
says global economic collapse is a
conspiracy fueled by more conspiracy
like the great reset
the name of the 50th annual meeting of
the world economic forum also
abbreviated wef
and the main topic was how to recover
economically from the virus from this
cobits thing right
we may see regional economic collapse
a total globally
collapse is highly unlikely he doesn't
explain why he just
has an opinion okay
that's just economics 101 yeah still not
saying that doesn't say anything we
we don't have a mechanism we need a
mechanism and find out why it's unlikely
okay
uh also the billionaire playboy club
will not let a total economic collapse
happen
we're talking about the illuminati here
okay
uh we have all these people who rule the
world the the rich people the wealthy
and they're not gonna let it happen
because what
uh having the capability to steer
economies they would lose their control
immediately in a total collapse okay
so yeah if there's a total collapse uh
these people you know uh the rich people
of the world
they come down to your level uh meaning
you know the grassroots level
uh and they're not going to let that
happen
that's how many people think out there
exactly how many people think out there
so uh this is their notion okay
they have all these hooded illuminati
and they're out there and they
talk to each other and they say why
don't we do this to the public why don't
we do that to the public you know
and so this way they keep all the sheep
within the corral okay
and this this is the notion a lot of
people have uh this follows uh just you
know essentially regurgitating what a
lot of people believe out there
okay um
here uh let's look at this
put it over here this is what uh that's
what i was talking about
um
this fell klaus schwab and he's talking
about this great reset
after the covet he said it's a good
thing that's kogit came around because
it allows us now to wipe the slate clean
and start all over again you know we can
do climate change
we can rearrange many things that uh
you know in society and economics and
politics that should have been done a
long time ago so he calls that the great
reset that's what this fellow was
talking about okay and uh
i like this the fourth industrial
revolution
i only heard about one the first
industrial revolution the only one okay
and then after that all i saw was a
collapse of manufacturing from then on
you know there was a big rise and then
finally a collapse which uh today
uh manufacturing is a very small portion
of gdp and of labor around 15
in each category
and
what does this fellow
klaus schwab say he says we stand on the
brink of a technological revolution oh
my god
that will fundamentally alter the way we
live work and relate to one another
in its scale scope and complexity the
transformation will be
uh unlike anything humankind has
experienced before okay
the first industrial revolution what
water and steam okay to power mechanized
uh production okay the second
electrical power okay the third one was
what electronics and information
and what's the fourth one well the
digital revolution internet i guess okay
kara is characterized by a fusion of
technologies that is blurring the lines
between the physical digital and
biological spheres
mighty words of this uh fellow klaus
schwab okay he's been around for quite a
while and he's shaking hands with a lot
of people out there in the high places
um
these are dreamers
uh you might say well he's got power
he's got influence he's got money yeah
but these are dreamers the fact that
they are illuminati that they
uh
have an overwhelming power or influence
at least over many politicians and
economists and so on and they themselves
can you know alter markets and they also
can get together and say well why don't
we do this why don't we do that yeah
they can do a lot of that stuff will
they avoid extinction
and i'm saying there's nothing anyone
can do about extinction extinction is
guaranteed it was guaranteed from the
day that mother nature spawned us this
is what people can't get through their
thick skulls they think these illuminati
control something i don't care what they
control they can control the world for
all i care
they will not be able to avoid
extinction because they will not be able
to salvage the economy
that's the problem no matter what they
do they can create more money they can
put money over here and put it over
there eventually money will have no
value
and when money has no value not if but
when money has no value that's it for
mankind
including all the illuminati there's
nothing they can do about it okay so i'm
saying the economic collapse is
guaranteed nothing you can do about it
the illuminati can stand on their heads
for all they i care you know they will
not be able to do anything about the
global economic collapse it's a
guaranteed thing that's going to come
okay we cannot grow forever on the
planet we cannot our economy cannot grow
forever especially when population
is now you know uh leveling off okay
we're we're producing fewer children
for the next generations and it's been
dropping since 1963
that's what now almost 50 years 50 years
that it's been steadily dropping it's
not like it dropped and it's going to
pick up now it's been steadily dropping
now the birth rate and why is that
important well because um
people mean demand that's what people
means okay
you have no demand companies close their
doors they lay off workers and now you
have less demand and the government all
that all they had a government can do is
just fill in the blanks by creating more
money that's it and we're going to
go with this cycle
until uh
money is no more until money has no
value okay so that's the argument
okay uh one person says related a little
more to extinction he says
oh ask a biologist what is life what is
it that makes an object alive
okay don't ask a biologist because they
never defined the word they never
defined the term life or alive or
living
they have no idea so we had to do that
okay alive or living a natural object
okay that moves against the path of
least resistance primarily gravity okay
anything that can move against gravity
by itself right okay
natural we're not talking about
artificial little airplanes and so on
balloons
uh we're talking about a natural object
okay that moves against gravity
primarily okay
now uh are all these other um objects
that you know airplanes can move against
gravity right
yeah but uh that's created by us so
we don't include them that's why we use
that word natural object it's only those
objects that mother nature creates not
those that are second hand made
artificially by
something that mother nature made which
is us okay so that's that's the
uh
that's the reason for the word natural
in that definition okay essentially a
living being has the ability to move
against gravity okay
and life is just a group of living
entities okay
uh is a virus alive no virus is a
molecule
it's a bacterium a bacteria meaning many
alive yes bacteria are alive so we have
some something that's made of cells
cell being the first entity that moves
against gravity okay primarily moves
against
path of least resistance
um
it's the first uh
living entity the cell that's the unit
of life whether it's plant or life it
does or or animal it doesn't matter uh
cell is the unit of life okay and uh
virus doesn't is not a cell it's not
compartmentalized it's just a uh a big
molecule okay and that's all it is
and uh so
virus is an inert entity it's not a
living entity the only time a virus
really moves is inside the body okay
once the
virus goes into the body it goes after
the cells and it uses a cell material to
make copies of itself that's the theory
whether you accept it or not okay that
is the theory if you got a better theory
you'd like to hear it okay
okay uh another issue related to this
covet thingy okay i disagree bill there
have been safe and ex inexpensive cures
out there try it and trust it talking
about how to cure cova okay
saying that maybe vaccine is not the
only way okay
many respected professionals have argued
against the response to this
response uh political is one thing
response uh medical like you know
creating the vaccines yeah i guess uh
you'll find uh that there are a lot of
doctors out there that maybe are
suspicious or a little skeptical about
vaccines okay
uh
i don't think the majority of them are i
think the majority i would say at least
90 percent are in favor of vaccines and
they
believe in vaccines that vaccines will
do something for you
there could be a percentage i would say
at most 10 percent that do not accept
vaccines or do not believe in vaccines
maybe they're holistic med doctors if
you can call them doctors okay i mean
you know a guy who uh runs around the
fire
you can say well he's he's a doctor he's
a witch doctor
maybe makes it rain you know i don't
know
and uh so there's been so much
fear-mongering in lies yeah that is true
and uh so
again you know i covered that the other
day saying that uh
some people take advantage or lots of
people take advantage they're trying to
make a buck out of this including the
big corporations that sell the medicines
and so on
doctors themselves maybe you know my
brother died this year and
he died of diabetes and
i would doubt it for a minute if the
hospital
told the government that he died of
coving because they get money for people
who die of cove they don't give money
for people who die of diabetes so uh i
would think that maybe just maybe
you know
they're making money off of this lots of
people making money out of this
okay uh
another issue person says have you taken
into account all of the side effects
from the vaccine
or how about
what the heck is in them
yeah again i i got the vaccine only
because i'm going to be traveling i got
my second shot i guess uh 23rd of
september i think it is
and
you know i got it not because of health
reasons i didn't get it for a year and a
half i mean i didn't care
and i still don't care i'm not worried
at all about my
catching the virus and the way i look at
it if i catch the virus and it does get
me and i'm not uh i don't have any
natural defenses uh i die that's it
that's how simple it is okay of course
the 20 year old has a different
perspective than i do you know i'm going
on 70 here
so uh we're we all have different
situations but i'm not concerned at all
about uh this vaccine or the covenant i
don't even think about it i don't lose
any sleep over it uh but again uh you
have people out there who have to deal a
lot with the public and they have you
know in their jobs and so on and so
they're in a different situation than a
fellow who stays at home or has home
office okay or is unemployed and those
people you know a lot of those people
have enough time to create a lot of
these um
conspiracy theories about
the illuminati and all that stuff
uh yeah it's a different story when you
have to work with a lot of people a lot
of those people a lot of those workers
are worried that
they're going to see
uh
they're going to come in contact with
all with lots of with the masses and
they have a higher chance of catching
the virus if there is a virus out there
right and so they they try to get that
shot in the arm okay and they say well
just in case i'm gonna get my shot
there's a lot of jobs that even are
requiring it demanding that you have the
vaccine otherwise they won't let you
work
and so you know there's a lot of these
situations out there everybody's
everybody's got a different situation my
situation i'm going to travel that's the
only situation i don't want the hassle
i've already went to iceland uh what was
in may and they gave me a little bit of
a hard time i don't want to go through
that again especially coming back to
germany here if you come from a fourth
world nation that that's on the list
uh like the united states for example
then they put you in quarantine okay in
fact i think it's holland i heard or
sweden one of those countries won't
accept americans right now
so uh yeah
with vaccines or not i guess
okay uh phil says i also got the shots i
swear many anti-vaxxers have got done uh
too but won't admit it yeah we have all
kinds of situations out there people who
are lying uh you know
the world is a
a very complex place
okay let's get on with the issue today
and what's the issue well the issue is
um
we're going to try this is the second
installment i'll be talking about
transparency and opacity why
uh
objects or substances are either
transparent or not transparent opac
opaque okay
the other day i mentioned one
uh
clue that mother nature gives us and he
goes more or less like this okay we did
a little experiment with my wife okay
and uh shown a laser through two lenses
that are polarized polarized lenses and
you can see all she does is turn them
around
and just by turning around the the uh
lens
the beam disappears okay
so
what i'm saying is that uh what you got
here is one clue that much mother nature
gives us okay
that um
maybe it's the alignment of molecules or
atoms whichever one you want there that
is producing this effect we're turning
something which is transparent into
something that is opaque okay that's the
idea behind polarization
now one fellow out there says
question that he says
polarization has absolutely nothing to
do with materials being transparent
okay
and so he says transparency is caused by
the transmission of light
and again i showed already in a couple
videos last couple videos that we're not
transmitting anything nothing is going
through the wall okay it doesn't matter
if the wall is uh of cement breaks or
whatever
or if it's air water or glass
the
light does not go through walls okay
it doesn't matter what wall you want
okay and what i'm saying is you have
every every material out there every
substance out there is made out of atoms
molecules okay
and light does not go through molecules
light does not go
through atoms okay
even though as uh the religion of
quantum holds
and they say an atom is mostly empty
space
well if that were so then you know light
should go through everything okay
and that's when they come up with all
these
attempts at explanations
which is what we're going to be
debunking here in this session and ones
that come after this okay so this falcon
continues as transparency and opacity of
objects depends on how light waves
interact with the materials of those
objects
well uh we can't talk about light waves
there's no such thing as a wave okay
there's a wave
and what you're seeing there is a bunch
of vectors that are moving
okay what is a vector it's just
magnitude and direction
so for this vowel to uh
talk about waves
in the 21st century you know i mean he's
outdated he should stay in the 19th
century there is no such thing as a wave
okay
uh
maxwell came up
one of the guys the other one went
frenel
they came up with a transverse wave
and uh what is a transverse wave just a
bunch of vectors moving vectors that's
math we don't have a physical object in
front of us
still at this point and uh
if you're strong about waves you got to
tell us what that wave is what is that
wave is it what i'm showing there a
bunch of vectors
if it's not a bunch of vectors tell us
what it is tell us what it's made out of
you know whatever
okay
so yeah
this is a problem people use the word
wave
and so let's go one by one here here you
have um waves
i covered this the other day airwaves
you can see that the particles of air
don't move from a to b
to the ear okay
what happens is the the molecules which
are close to the ear are banging against
the ear okay so you're shaking all the
air that's in the room
when you hear me okay and it's those
molecules which are close to your ear
which are
making you hear
yeah it's not the
molecules that i'm vibrating here that
are reaching your ear that's my point
okay same with water waves water waves
you see there's a couple of blue ones in
the center and there's just moving
locally
okay
so even if you're going to use waves
okay
waves don't move like you see there on
the bottom left
they're not like those vectors that are
moving over if anything uh if if light
is made of waves or gravity is made of
waves it should be local like you see
there with the airwaves and waterways
why would mother nature do something
different
for light okay
okay let me get rid of this
and then uh
here's
[Music]
a another aspect of it
uh maybe what this fellow is looking at
or think he's staring at he's thinking
it's waves but maybe it's a rope okay
so maybe uh this notion that people have
that there's waves moving from left to
right maybe nothing is moving maybe all
we have is a rope that is twirling in
place that gives the appearance
of a moving wave
right
so again you can't use the word wave
until you identify what the object is
wave is not a physical object okay
and then uh let me go to a definition of
what transparent is because this fellow
question whether
polarization
has anything to do with transparency or
opacity so we have to look at the
definitions here okay find out
um if polarization qualifies and here
you see uh
two sources uh put one uh the
dictionary.com the other one the
wikipedia okay and you can look up
others i'm sure you'll find exactly the
same thing you can go to the oxford
dictionary or whatever okay transparency
or transparent what is that having the
property of transmitting rays of light
through the substance
okay
but it's the only one that mentions what
you see there after that says so that
body situated beyond or behind can be
distinctly seen
the problem with the word seeing there
has to do with observers
making it subjective
i mean if we put a blind man
and he can't see he's oh it's opaque to
me
no kidding
okay so uh
so this scene thing is is something that
uh whether that has anything to do with
transparency okay we'll get to that in a
second what is opaque what doesn't
mention anything about scene it just
says impenetrable to the light not
allowing light to pass through which is
exactly the opposite of transparent
meaning that transparent is just when it
allows light to go through
not necessarily seen okay and again it
shows that the mathematicians never
define words scientifically and that's
why we get into these problems we get
into these problems because we don't
know if we're talking about an objective
criterion meaning whether light goes
through something whether you're blind
or not though the light will go through
a polarizer you know uh or not depending
on what direction they are
and uh so it doesn't matter if you're
blind or not because what's happening to
the polarizers is independent of
opinions on the other hand whether you
can see something or not that introduces
an observer into the definition
and of course a mathematician a person
who can't tell the difference between
these things that's why they don't have
any rational definitions in mathematical
physics okay
and wikipedia again doesn't even mention
the scene the observer it just says the
physical property of allowing light to
pass through the material
that's what everybody understands for
transparent and what is opacity the
opposite the measures of impenetrability
to electromagnetic or other kinds of
radiation especially visible light
no notion whatsoever whether you can see
or not okay so the this c
thingy
is the one that uh
you got a question okay
but let's introduce it what the hell
let's let's put it in there okay let's
make sure we cover all the bases
let's accept observers okay
if you have two polarizing lenses
and you shine a light through
and you're on the other side
okay you're on the other side of the two
lenses
well at one point you know the laser
hits your eye and you see it
maybe you go blind
and on the other it doesn't
okay so even if you were going to put
the observer into polarization
it fits the definition of transparency
and opacity
from the screen's point of view which is
the observer's point of view
which is the opposite end of the laser
right you either see it
meaning it's uh
transparent
or you don't see it meaning it's opaque
okay so yes polarization does have
something to do with transparency and
opacity first and second it's one of the
clues that mother nature gives us as to
why
some objects
are transparent others are opaque
but
to
prevent you know
to get ahead of people out there it's
not the only
it's not the only mechanism people say
it's not the only mechanism
let me cover the other mechanism allow
me a chance to cover the other
mechanisms before you open your big fat
mouths okay
and this is the problem people say oh
but how about this and how about that
well
let me get there okay and that's why i'm
taking it one uh installment at a time
today's the second installment the other
day it was polarization it gives us one
clue today we're going to look at
another clue okay
if you if you bear with me
okay so let's first make sure one more
time that we get rid of the mathematical
method because we're not going to find
out how mother nature does her stuff
with this so-called
uh method that comes from the 17th
century so i'm going to repeat this
you can go take a coffee break and then
come back if you've already heard it but
i got to go through this for people who
are new to the site
we don't follow the mathematical method
here okay we follow the scientific
method here what is the mathematical
method it's the one that's covered in
high school and college okay
and we have a paradigm shift and uh the
paradigm shift that says that science is
not all this other stuff that they
taught you
science is explanations
what is science not well it's none of
these it's uh not observation we don't
do observing we don't gawk in science we
don't look without understanding okay so
we don't just say oh observe i observe
that's the first step of the scientific
method no no the fact that you observed
doesn't mean that you
processed
and did something with your observation
we don't do predictions
okay we don't
science is not about the future science
is about the past okay we do
mass extinctions not
uh the day that humans will die okay
among others okay so we don't do
predictions that's astrology we don't do
experiments in science we do not do
experiments you heard it here okay
[Music]
you know i'm not drunk
in science we do not do experiments
it's in religion where they do
experiments
in science what we do is explain
experiments
okay there's a difference between doing
an experiment repeatable and otherwise
and explaining it you have to explain
why what happened how it happened
okay in physics okay so doing an
experiment is not saying here i i do an
experiment every day all the time i let
go of the pen and it falls to the ground
repeatable let's do it again and we let
go of the pencil and it falls to the
ground
so i did the experiment
i'm a scientist because i did an
experiment
okay so doing experiments is not science
it's explaining them that has something
to do with science okay and the problem
here is that people introduce
observation prediction and uh um
experiments
uh and they say oh we're scientists
i don't think so okay what's the purpose
of experiments is to create evidence
what's the purpose of evidence is it to
get your nobel prize
the purpose of evidence is to convince
the jury
okay that's what evidence is for it's to
persuade convince
convert and recruit
that's the purpose of evidence so we
don't use evidence that's religion
okay we don't present evidence in the of
of the existence of god for example okay
that's not science
okay so we don't do any of these things
we don't do measurement we don't do
description why because it's
mathematical descriptions just an
equation
that doesn't tell me how something
happened why it happened the cause the
mechanism
okay so we don't measurement or math of
any kind math has nothing to do with
science math is not the language of
science math is not the language of
physics the language of physics is
illustration
i need to see the mechanism i want you
to make a movie of the mechanism it's
called illustration that's the language
of physics okay for that you need
objects and for that you need to define
what an object is for the purposes of
physics
okay uh we don't pay attention to
credentials we don't care if you got a
phd especially if you got a phd out of
town cambridge or harvard in
mathematical physics for sure uh it's
worthless
they tipped you you should ask for your
money back okay we don't vote for
theories no democracy in science and uh
we don't win prizes
science is not a beauty contest or the
olympics you know we don't
uh get medals for running faster or
anything like that for having more
knowledge or king of knowledge no such
thing in science and of course
we don't censor like they do in
mathematical physics
uh
especially physical interpretations they
we don't censor those from anyone on the
contrary we want to hear them we want to
hear as many physical interpretations
that you can come up with no math no
equations no experiments just the just
the uh just the facts
like the policeman just the facts ma'am
just the facts and when we went and as
far as facts are concerned we're talking
about explanation we want you to tell us
a mechanism
you don't have a mechanism you're not a
scientist you're not a physicist
okay
okay so what are these mathematicians
used well for the last 400 years at
least
for more than that they've been using
particles but for the last 400 years
they've been using these two particles
and and transverse waves
uh what's the problem with the first
problem is that the particles ain't
particles okay uh quantum does not use
particles corpuscles uh little beads or
tiny grains of dust
no what uh quantum uses are uh
concepts mathematical concepts that they
converted into particles or they
uh represent with particles
that's the first problem so there is no
physical object when they talk about
particles so they chose this word
particles which is very misleading for
the common people because common people
say okay i know what a particle is
it's only when you press them and say
well what do you mean by particle do you
mean like
a little corpuscle and that's when they
explain well no you got to take 10 years
of math to know what a particle is
that's the way they put it okay
transverse wave i just covered it uh no
such thing as a transverse wave while
you're staring at is a bunch of moving
vectors
so if you're going to go with
mathematical physics they don't have a
physical object they don't have
particles and they don't have transverse
wave we don't have nothing okay so this
is a problem so they can't give you a
physical interpretation with abstract
concepts
okay it's important to keep this in mind
okay because
a lot of people use these words waves
and particles to give a physical
interpretation
and unless you know you understand you
are
conscious of the fact that there are no
such things as particles and waves
you know you're going to swallow
whatever they they feed you
but once you understand that there are
no particles and waves then what you're
hearing from these mathematical physics
is bunk is garbage
plain and simple okay because they don't
have a physical interpretation okay
and uh so here we go uh here are some of
the uh youtubers
that try to explain
opacity and transparency
and they're gonna use the particle in
the way okay here you have a whole bunch
of them you know and uh if you go in
there just look up uh
uh why is glass transparent or why is
water transparent or anything related to
these uh subjects opacity and
transparency you're gonna have all these
uh individuals tell you uh the party
line they're gonna
you know they're just gonna recite what
they learned in college essentially
okay
and you can look them up in youtube
you'll find all these folks the problem
is that you don't need to see all these
fellows okay
you look at one you've seen them all
because they all say exactly the same
thing
and each one starts the same way they
say if you go to other sites they'll
tell you something that's wrong let me
tell you the right way and he tells you
the same thing the other guy told you
okay so what is the right way what is
the the official way of
uh regarding transparency and regarding
um opacity
well here's uh one fellow uh i've talked
about him in the past mr curly okay
and what does curly tell us okay well
he's got his side and he tells us the
following he starts with his atom okay
and you talk about irrationality here it
goes okay
atoms are mostly empty space
okay
doesn't look like much to work with
okay i have mostly empty space okay now
the next part is is what really
uh shows you how irrational quantum
mechanics is
look at this this electrons do not have
size
yeah yeah yeah i heard it like he said
it like that exactly okay these are uh
verbatim okay electrons do not have size
they're point particles
well i don't know what a point particle
is but a point you know you put a little
dot with your pencil you have something
there and this guy says
it's not even that it's nothing it does
not have any size no radius no diameter
no nothing you're talking what's what
doesn't have size nothing
that's what has no size it's called
nothing
okay so he starts out like that then he
says something even weirder says
electrons are simultaneously everywhere
here you have a i mean these are his
words okay i'm not putting them in his
mouth you can look at his uh his video
okay
and it says electrons are simultaneously
everywhere
so you have something that has no size
but it's
everywhere covers the entire universe
okay that's uh
i mean i cannot even imagine what he's
talking about at this point and then he
gives you know the final uh cherry on
the uh on the cake says uh electrons can
only occupy certain energy levels
in an atom right
so
we have something that has no size
which is everywhere and which occupies
only one energy level
well that's the end of his presentation
right there i mean i haven't understood
anything have you can you make sense of
what he just said
these are his words
and this is a guy who studied at the
university i think he's got a master's
at least probably a phd i don't really
know
um
he makes his uh money
you know on the internet
and this is what he tells people out
there what he
learned by wrote
in college and so he just regurgitates
it in a language that would be appealing
to the general public
okay so what is he saying he's saying
electrons do not have sides they're
everywhere
but they can occupy they're everywhere
but they can occupy
orbitals they can happen by
energy bands or energy levels
scary stuff
okay but let's continue let's see if we
can find out something about this again
now you can see there that's what an
atom looks like with the electron
rolling around it looks like nothing
absolutely nothing
so
why does he say this well he that's his
introduction because he's going to say
therefore a photon is going to hit one
one electron right
no matter what
because the
electron is everywhere
okay
uh i thought it was in an energy level
lower energy level so how can it hit
that one well because the electron is
everywhere so no matter where the
electron hits it's going to hit an
electron
where a photon hits it's going to hit an
electron that's what he's saying
well yeah that's like covering all the
bases i mean i haven't understood
anything so far from him what is he
saying
and it says electrons will absorb the
photon okay
uh
i don't know if i had something else yet
oh no matter what
okay
uh
right because uh the electron is
everywhere and so
what the electron does is absorb this
photon this energy because they use the
word photon energy interchangeably
okay whatever energy is we never figure
that out okay
okay so this is how he starts his
presentation introducing his atom i
haven't understood anything but let's
see if we can bear with him see if we
can find out what this is all about
maybe he learned something today
maybe at least in the negative way right
okay so here it is this is his
explanation for opacity and transparency
and i want you to pay close attention
now okay because this is the party line
they all say the same thing by the way
okay
okay so here goes okay so this is what
uh curly says he says when a photon
comes along the electron gets excited
and jumps to a higher energy level okay
so it looks like the electron hits
the the photon hits the electron and
because of that boost that bumping that
collision the electron gets bumped up to
a higher energy level that's what he's
saying this is this is a starting point
okay
an electron in a gas molecule releases a
photon
okay so it receives and releases okay we
got it
an electron in a liquid or solid
molecule the uh the other molecules are
too close and the electron calms down by
releasing that energy to the adjacent
molecules in other words if the elec if
the electron absorbs the molecule that
the i'm sorry the photon then it's going
to use that to shake the other molecules
that are elbow to elbow with it okay
this is increases the thermal energy
instead of releasing a photon okay so
he's saying now it's absorbed but
instead of releasing the photon and
releasing this energy it uses this
energy to do some um
thermal stuff some you know it's going
to shake the atoms and molecules that
are next to it
okay it's still absorbed by the electron
but immediately rejected
the energy here here's important part
okay the energy gap in glass is too big
for visible light okay so you have
visible light that goes somewhere from
the red to the blue okay
uh
infra red is a little beyond our
capability to see and ultraviolet is
above you know
our ability to see
okay so it is absorbed by energy but
immediately rejected the energy gap is
in glass is too big for visible light
to excite an electron the photon has to
have an energy of at least 138
nanometers that's uv light
okay so uv light is invisible to us
and
so if you want to excite that electron
you can't do it with visible light you
need to get to that
edge where um visible light becomes uv
light higher energy and at that point
then yes the electron gets bumped to the
uh higher energy level and you can you
uh in in the uh that electron or that
atom that substance becomes opaque
okay
so this is the the issue okay this is
how it's going to explain it and it says
if visible light cannot excite an
electron it won't get absorbed as
thermal energy
it will it still gets absorbed just as
vibrations in the l just as vibrations
in the electron instead and since the
electrons reject those photons they make
it out the other side okay so if the
photon is not absorbed it just goes
through
and that's where all these people get
the idea that light goes through
substances
and he says uh
finally he says transparency you know he
shouts it out like saying that's how you
make transparent things okay
so uh
let's uh see if we understood what uh
curly said here okay i want people to
understand this okay
here's a photon it comes
if it doesn't have the energy
enough energy to bump to strike
that electron and push it to a higher
energy level
okay
then uh
it um
that photon
goes through essentially
and that's in a
substance that is transparent
okay if instead it hits the uh electron
well uh one of the two it
it gets re-emitted or it uh
it uh just
that electron will um
translate that into
a thermal energy and essentially shake
the
atoms and molecules that are next to it
okay we got and in that case it's opaque
so opacity uh turns it into thermal
energy at best or just absorbs it and uh
in the case of transparency
uh the photon is not strong enough not
powerful enough not energetic enough to
boost it to a higher level okay
we got that
it's important for you to get it i know
some people will want to rush through
but i need to make sure everybody
understands it okay because we got a
punchline for all these people
okay and uh just in case i want to make
sure that this is the
party line it's everywhere here you have
the same thing from quora okay
and fellow says why is glass transparent
okay dense materials like glass or lid
are almost entirely empty space great so
everything should be transparent right
the air and water in the glass
are almost entirely empty space good so
light should just go through right the
little photon the little wave or
whatever
the primary reason glass is clear is
because it has a large band gap
aha so we have a difference in uh energy
levels right and here's the electron at
the lower energy level and there's a big
gap for it to jump to the next energy
level this is the idea okay the large
band gap is important for transparency
because one of the main ways light can
be affected by matter is when an
electron absorbs a photon we're going to
absorb that photon again okay the
electron jumps to a higher energy level
you got that okay higher energy level
and the photon disappears
okay so it's absorbed it's opaque okay
the electrons at the bottom of the band
gap can only absorb if the other photon
gives them enough energy so if it's weak
it doesn't have the energy okay it
doesn't have the
the uh
the umph
to push that electron to the next energy
level that's what they're saying okay so
they're all saying the same thing
keep that in mind they're all saying the
same thing they all went to the same
school
okay
uh that is only photons whose energy is
larger
okay it's gotta be mightier okay then
the size of the band gap can be absorbed
we got that okay i hope everybody
is tuned in and understands what i just
said okay
uh and i'm gonna rub one more in there
okay before we move on to explaining all
this stuff
okay here's the mechanism i've
illustrated it so that you
have no doubts okay
they're saying here comes the electron
you'll see it in a second here
hits the i'm sorry the photon and hits
the electron electron jumps to a higher
energy level this is essentially what
they're saying
okay
and if it jumps to a higher energy level
it absorbs the photon therefore you
don't see that photon doesn't get to
your eyes
if on the other hand you know the um
um
the the electron does not absorb the
photon
then that photon reaches your eye okay
so that's the that's the theory
we all
got it i hope everybody got it okay
is there something wrong with this
let's find out
uh we'll let mr bean
uh show us why something is wrong with
this
theory this explanation here's mr bean
okay
and he's in a one-way mirror okay so he
thinks he's in front of the mirror but
the people on the other side
looking through the same piece of glass
okay same thickness same material they
can see right through the glass they can
see him but he can't see them
so if i were to shine a laser
okay from one end or from the other we
would have a different result the same
material
same glass okay
uh
you can say what's coated here whatever
the light is different here yeah i don't
care about any of that because we're
talking about the material here we're
talking about the photon from a laser
okay
hitting uh being absorbed or not
absorbed by the same material from one
end or the other end
okay
and so the glass is the same in both
cases whether you're on one side or the
other if i shine a laser from one side i
should be able to see
uh through it and if i sign from the
other side i'm gonna get a reflection
so we got a problem with uh this notion
that
the electron absorbs the photon because
here this is not the case it absorbs it
in one case and not in the other
okay
well we're not going to stop there we
want to make sure we trash quantum
mechanics completely okay
so let's make sure we we do away with
the
this theory that quantum mechanics has
of absorbing photons okay
and um here here you have a situation
very simple okay
and uh here we have uh
glass which is opaque and how did we
make this glass well we originally
started with a very thin sheet which is
transparent and the more glasses we put
in there the greener it becomes
okay it becomes opaque at some point if
you make glass very very thick
it's completely opaque
it's only very thin glass that we use
like for windows and so on window panes
that are transparent
okay the more glass you put uh
the um
the darker that glass becomes
okay
and um
so let me show you this
uh where is it
okay
you can see it there that if you put one
glass on top of the other it gets darker
and darker and darker at some point it
becomes opaque
okay so what happened here
if
if if this is an issue of
the photon being absorbed
or not absorbed
are we seeing that the more glasses we
put
the photon
gains energy
until it's finally absorbed by an
electron which jumps to the higher
energy level
how did that photon gain energy as it
went through thicker and thicker glass
you would think it's the opposite if
anything it loses energy
i mean he would think right but
assuming all else being equal you know
here we have a photon that was not
absorbed but at some point it gets
absorbed because you don't see the
photon coming out of the other side
light does not get through that though
that thick glass
it's opaque
and what what do they say the reason for
that is that
the electron absorbed that photon
and the only way it could do so is if
the photon has sufficient energy to
boost it to a higher energy level
okay so here we have this photon it's
got the same energy that came from the
sun right from your flashlight or
whatever okay and it goes through the
first glass no problem no big deal
but as it tries to go deeper and deeper
and deeper through that whole glass at
some point it gets absorbed and doesn't
get to your eye which is on the other
side
but for that according to quantum you
need more energy
how did the photon gain more energy by
going through thicker glass
okay so that's the first problem we got
there and um
so i ran an experiment and uh it goes
like this
this is a uh
transparent uh piece of plastic okay uh
some
some material i don't even know what it
is i don't care
you can see my nose you can see my mouth
okay
what happens if
i put a stack of these
can you see my nose in my mouth now
okay so uh one sheet
no problem
semi-transparent you can say almost
transparent
many sheets
not transparent
so uh what happened
to this photon in it's got trouble
uh getting through it was absorbed by
the electrons simply because of the
thickness of the
of the layer in front of it
you see the problem
and uh
just in case did a little experiment
okay it goes something like this uh we
have a candle there
and i'm going to put a single sheet of
these
and you can see the light of the candle
through it okay it's got all these
little lines fine but when we put the
whole stack
you know
you can barely see it and the more
of those sheets that you put you won't
see it at all
you won't see the the fire
at all you won't see the light on the
candle
okay so this is one sheet
okay
and here are many sheets
is there a difference
yeah of course there is a difference
and what was the reason well the reason
has to do simply with putting more in
there
more sheets so we have all these
transparent films the more of these
transparent films you put
at some point it becomes opaque
now isn't that a magic trick
take all the transparencies so the
addition of transparent material gives
you opaque
okay
we got that
okay here's uh just in case i did it
with a laser okay i pointed the laser at
many of these sheets and it doesn't go
through
but when i point the laser at one sheet
okay just confirming here see there's
one sheet you can see it goes right
through
okay
so just wanna make sure that uh
we're all on top of that okay that we
all understand that uh putting many
of these transparent films you can
create opacity
so
how does the quantum explanation
uh fit into that here we have the photon
it's got a
gain energy
to boost the electron to a higher level
and these people are essentially saying
that this electron going through more
films
gain more energy enough to boost that
last electron to a higher energy level
and that's why the film
is transparent it is okay
yeah sure
okay
and uh here uh
here's another experiment for you to do
at home okay this is a very expensive
experiment i don't know if it's within
your budget okay and always do it in the
presence of a relativist never do it
alone okay
and it goes like this you get two pieces
of tape
the only difference between these two
pieces of tape is the thickness of the
tape okay i want you to understand that
okay the difference is just the
thickness that's it this one is almost
gone i need to buy a new one okay and
this is almost full
now i want you to see
here on this one okay let me show you
this see you can see the line right
through the uh through the tape
the tape is transparent you can see the
cardboard line there where the cardboard
has been rolled around see that's that
cardboard inside there and it's been
you can see it you can see it right
through the tape
this one you cannot see it no matter how
you turn it
okay so here i'm turning it around and
you can't see the lines no matter what
so even though this is transparent tape
and this is transparent tape
a bunch of these
make it opaque
one of these or very few of these make
it transparent
okay many against a few
okay so now we have learned
a uh second way that mother nature
does opacity versus transparency and it
has to do with how many layers
we put in there one layer transparent
many layers not transparent anymore
and that debunks the nonsense that
quantum mechanics says that
it's got to do with the absorption
of
uh photons by electrons
they would have to explain why that last
electron finally absorb or you know one
of the
atoms in there one of the electrons in
there absorbed that photon okay
why
uh
you know i mean
how how is it that by making it thicker
what's that got to do with an electron
absorbing a a photon and jumping to a
higher energy level
did the
by making it thicker did the photon
gain energy is that what they're saying
okay so here are the conclusions for
today okay
and it goes something like this
uh first uh clue i talked about the
other day mother nature does
transparency opacity in polarization so
polarization
is
one of the clues mother nature is giving
us and how she does transparency and
opacity okay
if the films are aligned
you have transparency if the films are
not aligned one is in this case 90
degrees to another um
then you have opacity and so
i asked the following you can't see
through your brick wall
but the question is if if you had the
power of god and could align every atom
in the brick
everyone is so perfectly aligned in some
way some fashion
would you be able to see through the
wall
because again light does not go through
atoms through any kind of wall
whether air water or glass or cement
water is relayed from one atom to
another
okay
and so if if we could align every atom
in a brick
or in the cement or whatever
would you be able to see through your
brick wall
that's the question okay does it have to
do with alignment well at least in one
circumstance or one
situation it does and that's
polarization by merely rotating or
misaligning right
atoms molecules we can produce
transparency or opacity
okay
so that is one clue
mathematical method irrational okay you
can't follow that to explain for example
opacity and
transparency
irrational what is it to simulate
physical interpretation with transverse
waves or zero d point particles which is
what quantum mechanics proposes
uh what does classical mechanics propose
okay we're talking about 19 centurers
here you know people like james maxwell
and so on what did they propose well
they said well discrete corpuscles
but the problem with discrete corpuscles
and waves which is where he really
proposed right but they were all
thinking in terms of particles and waves
all the time okay
um
you can't simulate the properties of
light
you can't do it with discrete particles
you can't do it with waves because
there's no such thing as a wave
and you can't do it with zero
dimensional particles which is what
quantum proposes and so that's the end
of
those physical interpretations you can't
explain
with whatever they propose to date
okay and uh so quantum mechan theory
uh that zero d photons such as zero d
uh push zero d electrons to a higher
energy levels of or bands is debunked
okay it's it's bunk
okay and all we have to do is just put
more layers of whatever substance and we
show that it's got nothing to do in
those cases at least right
again we're explaining the second
version here the second installment uh
in those uh experiments those situations
you cannot explain with this absorption
of a photon by uh an electron okay and
so yeah that's the second clue of mother
nature that she does transparency
opacity
by changing the thickness
okay so that's the installment for today
okay let's get to the questions
that people ask comments
here's the first one
sorry can you tell everyone the
definition of shape again
[Laughter]
you said shape is what distinguished the
inside of an object from the outside of
it and we can treat both the inside and
outside as objects then you said shape
is the inability to blend with the
immediate surrounding or environment
well i already answered that question
like twice already but this guy is not
picking up on that but okay i'll answer
it one more time okay hopefully the last
time so i don't want to bore the crowd
out there
okay so here here's the the problem with
this thought of saying okay
these are the words that define the word
object that which has shape there's just
four words there okay
so here's the first question to him i'll
answer with a question why didn't he ask
me to define the word that
how about the word which
or has i mean are those words easier to
define than the word shape
okay so that's the first issue why did
he pick on the word shape doesn't he i
mean i'm sure he can tell me
easier what the word shape means and be
able to define what the word that or
which
mean okay those are much harder to
define
okay so that's the first issue um here
let's go to the second issue here it
goes
okay
and that's that in science we don't
define every word in the dictionary
okay so you can't just continue saying
well how do you define that and so you
define the word that and say well this
is how we define the word that and you
go through all these words they say well
how do you define and
and how do you define or how about the
period what do you mean by period
we don't go through all that we don't
define words just to please the devil's
advocate okay we define the words that
we're going to use
to explain the mechanism the crucial
words that are necessary to explain
a phenomenon how something works
and
for that we and for the rest of the
presentation we use ordinary speech
okay just normal understanding of words
if there's a critical word that you
don't understand
i say in you say what do you mean by n
well i mean in you know like
the
dog went in the house or into the house
or whatever you know
so do i have to explain what in means
and so on how many words you want me to
explain every one of them i'm going to
spend the whole day explaining every
word in the dictionary is that what
science is about
is that what physics is about no we're
trying to understand the mechanism okay
and in this case we define the word
object as that which has shape
and the purpose of that is to
distinguish it from what the
mathematicians do
which is saying that it's see or touch
so we have to choose
a criterion
or criteria
for defining the word object are we
going to choose shape or are we going to
choose c
touch
that's the entire issue
you can't say well since you couldn't
define shape i'm going back to see and
touch
that's what we want to avoid see you
touch
our verbs
verbs
are preceded by objects so you can't use
a verb to define the word object and uh
more more than that um
you know c and touch require an
experiment and also require two objects
only something
if you see something there's two objects
in the in the field of view in the movie
and if you touch something there's two
objects in your movie already okay so
you got a problem
okay science defines only those terms
that make or break a theory shape is not
a key word
we don't define the word shape because
it's not a key word people who harp on
the word shape are mentally [ __ ]
individuals
who think they're smart
okay
and all they do is show their ignorance
because again all we're trying to do is
compare uh the word shape against c and
touch which are the current
uh parameters or words that are used to
define the word object okay shape is an
adjective okay that's what it is say no
it's a noun but that's an ordinary
speech
in physics shape is an adjective it
qualifies a noun what is a noun only
objects can serve as noun and nouns as
fit in physics
okay we can't use the word motion or the
word orbit
as a noun in physics those are verbs for
the purposes of physics and so physics
has a different language
that's what this site is about it
debunks all the nonsense from
mathematical physics which has
introduced words of ordinary speech like
orbit and motion into orbital for
example and turned them into nouns into
physical objects
brought in wave it says a vortex it
calls plasma a thing those are not
things for the purposes of physics okay
it takes a long time for someone to
learn the language of physics
okay so uh shape is a property of
objects shape merely describes okay and
science is about explaining
okay so there you have your answer
hopefully this time the fellow reads it
or sees it or whatever because he's
asked this question like two or three
times now
okay um
go with the next question here
comment
father says
the mathematical method
and he goes through it he says the math
the math magicians made up the math
magician method yeah correct okay you
got that one right the mathematician
method has five basic steps plus one
feedback step aha okay
make an observation ask a question form
a hypothesis or testable explanation
make a prediction test the prediction
and then do it all over again
[Laughter]
yeah that is the ridiculous mathematical
method okay
what is an accepted mathematician's
method is a requirement for any kind of
mathematics well i don't know if they'll
agree with you on that okay i think uh i
think math is an important part of the
mathematical method and what is involved
in ex
in accepted mathematicians method is
experiment observation and prediction
yeah correct that's what they use in the
mathematical method
uh but we do science a little
differently okay science is a little
different
and here uh here you see the uh problems
with the 17th century so-called
scientific method which is really the
mathematical method okay
and this is why it's unscientific
first of all it has statements of
authority okay uh
you know they turned all these opinions
into facts
uh then they have uh unjustified
opinions and beliefs
which uh is religion that's what this
leads to okay
uh tradition you know they they uh say
well we always done it like that so
we're not gonna change now and and then
we have democracy on top of that
everybody does it this way and that's
how we're gonna continue doing it well
none of that uh has anything to do with
science and science you have to get in
the ring and fight for your definitions
for your theories okay for everything
that you propose and these people want
to do it on the basis of tradition says
well this is how i learned it in college
i learned it from the previous
generation who learned it from the
previous generation we're just going to
keep it that way
that's not science that sounds like
religion okay
and so
this mathematical method when we apply
it it has led to irrational explanations
and here are a couple examples gravity
is supposedly the warp concept known as
space-time
you warp a concept and that's gravity
and that's why the pen falls to the
floor
then you have a particle can be at two
places at once that's a quantum thingy
okay
how can a particle be at two places at
once what sense does that make is that
what this uh scientific revolution
created after so many 400 years you know
then they ended up with a planetary
model uh big bang creationism and they
say that there's something called a
black hole which is a zero dimensional
yeah you heard it right zero dimensional
singularity which moves stars around
how do you move a star with a zero
dimensional
nothing
as uh
like that photon all these are
singularities okay you have the photon
the zero dimension on those sides the
singularity that's at the center of the
black hole is zero dimensional
no size and this creates an event
horizon which is a cons a concept okay
it's like the heat of a
campfire okay
and uh that's how they move stars around
oh yeah
only after the fourth beer okay
okay so yeah
that mathematical method
uh has nothing to do with science it's
got to do strictly with religion
okay uh somebody said you have to be
[ __ ] okay to think reflections come
off the surface of water
the comment is correct this fault says
we can see very clear reflection off the
mirror inside the water okay
and we did an experiment with ons my son
and uh what we did we put a mirror in a
trash can the bottom of the trash can
okay and then we poured water as you can
see there we're gonna be pouring water
in there and we can still see the mirror
throughout
at all points in time we see the mirror
in there this guy's saying well you can
see i don't know what he's trying to say
there because he didn't explain in any
detail okay but there you can see the
mirror at the bottom of the pool and
we're seeing that through a bunch of
water
okay
and so this is the this is the issue
people think that they get their
reflection
from the surface of the water that's the
standard
explanation out there okay do you get
some reflection from the surface yeah
but um you throw a little coin at the
bottom of the pool okay
and you can see it through several
feet of water
you see the coin down there
and what this person's arguing he says
well you're seeing really the reflection
of the
from the top from the surface of the
water
so here's the million dollar question
for you how did the light from
the coin
get to the surface of the water
i'll grant that okay so i see the
reflection from the surface of the water
fine
uh if i cover the
the uh coin down there with something
will i still see the reflection out
there from the surface of the water
so somehow the
light from the coin got to the surface
of the water
so when i'm staring at
the coin
like we just showed there
i'm
staring at it through the water all the
way to the bottom
okay and if as we say light does not go
through atoms through any kind of wall
whether it be air or water or glass
it's relayed
okay at the speed of light from one atom
to another okay goes all the way down
there and comes back along the same
channel more or less unless the water
moved a little bit but if the water's
stationary if we could keep it there
right um
then it would be almost a straight line
back and forth because it travels at the
speed of light
and that's the signal the torsion okay
okay so yeah uh no
we don't see it only from the surface
you do see some reflection from the
surface okay there is reflection from
glass there is reflection from
uh water
there is even reflection from air
whether you believe it or not there is
reflection from normal air
that's why air has a refractive index a
very small reflect a refractive index
but uh areas not completely transparent
like empty space okay
so yeah there is some reflection from
surfaces but you still are looking at
light that came from the coin at the
bottom of the pool to
the surface of the water
okay next issue
fella says
uh
a second
here it says for the sake of simplicity
let's say there is only one atom in your
laser pointer uh-huh so we have a laser
pointer here right here okay there's
your pointer
and um
it says there's only one atom okay uh
this atom is the source of the rope
pumping
okay so
remember the the um atom is pumping it's
not the rope it's uh the atom that's
pumping it's torquing the rope okay and
of course this atom is connected by a
rope with a receiving atom on the moon
so yeah so you have an atom here on the
earth part of a laser we're going to
shine it at the retro reflector on the
moon that's what he's referring to we
get a signal back okay that's the laser
ranging experiment nasa and russia uh
are doing or
are still doing i think there's five of
them out there in the moon okay for
those of you who are not flat earthers
now you point your laser in another
direction to another atom of course also
connected with a source atom okay how
does the source adam know what rope
should it should it starts to pump in
other words he's saying if if i have a
laser pointed in your direction right
and here's he's talking about a single
atom this is the issue here he's talking
about a single atom if i point it in a
different direction that atom is pumping
in all direction radially
so you're saying why do i see the laser
going in one direction and not in all
directions that's his issue okay
if it pumps the ropes to all atoms in
the universe okay
to which it is connected it must be one
mighty pumper
okay yeah all atoms are mighty pumpers
they all pump to every atom in the
universe but it still doesn't explain
why only some atoms in the general
direction to where your laser pointer is
pointing can feel the rope torquing and
he's talking about the frequency saying
well here you have a high frequency i
only see it in one direction
i don't see it in all directions that's
his that's his argument okay
okay so let's understand what he's
saying so it's an important question
okay so what do we answer we say this is
from the internet okay
it's about lasers and essentially it's
our argument laser light is directional
you can't do this with one atom because
one atom is not directional one atom is
radial in every direction but what we're
going to do here is we're going to
reorient light in a given direction
we're going to give it a
a boost in a given direction okay
with a laser whereas a laser generates a
very
tight beam a flashlight produces light
that is diffused and you can see it here
see that's diffused light
and that's laser light see if i can
point to something here
i guess i'll point it to me
okay you can see that this one is it's
just pinpoint okay there
and this one
there it goes
it goes in every direction so there's a
difference between a laser which is
directed and a regular light which tends
to diverge okay
because laser light is coherent it stays
focused for vast distances even to the
moon and back
so that's uh the short answer okay
that's the quick answer to your question
okay we're talking about directional
light okay and of course that needs a
little more explanation all i'm saying
is uh you can't simulate this or can't
answer this question using your situ the
situation you're
you're proposing which is a single atom
we have no directional layer whatever
that means to you now in order to have
directional you need electricity in the
case of uh laser and you need to have
all those atoms aligned in some way and
shooting the laser in a given direction
you orient it there it's more or less
what i did um with the
uh
is it with the
accelerators i worked with they're known
as implanters and we directed
atoms along the beam line okay
and so
yeah you can you can do that with gases
you can
you know uh ionize them and then you can
with magnets you can orient them towards
a wafer and so you can have a beam it's
called a beam and you direct things okay
it's not like uh you know gas goes
everywhere
fill the gas uh you know air into a
balloon and that air is everywhere
that's not how you do it in a
you can take that into a beam line and
orient it anywhere you want
okay another one uh
says
make visible the invisible the ropes
well there i made it visible
there you see it
okay so
and here uh here's another rope okay
here's
you see it
that's a visible rope okay that's a rope
known as a rope uh you don't believe me
you think i'm uh
creating a hoax here uh go to your
hardware store and ask for a rope
and uh two-strand rope okay and they'll
sell you something like this
and you'll see that a rope is visible
yeah all ropes as far as i'm concerned
are visible because
an object is is visible simply because
an object is that which has shape so
there should be no reason for you unless
you're blind not to see it okay
okay but um here's the issue uh
try to do that now with your quantum
particle
uh what is it uh what did these folks
say uh no size
zero dimensional point particle
what does that look like please make
that one visible what are you gonna put
whatever you put there is not going to
be zero dimensional no size
and how about the transverse wave
well the transverse wave is made out of
electric fields and magnetic fields okay
what is a field made on it well it's
made out of vectors
what is a vector magnitude and direction
please make visible magnitude and
direction what are you going to put a
an arrow an engine arrow is that what
you're going to draw for magnitude and
direction
so uh yeah try to make visible first
the quantum particle try to make visible
the vector
and if you can't make that visible well
you don't have uh any
physical object on the other hand the
rope yeah there you see it it's visible
well we can make any rope visible if you
have doubts go to your hardware store
buy yourself a two-strand rope and
you'll know what we're talking about
rope is always visible it's an object
these are not objects
the point particle and the uh
wave those are not objects those are not
things
a wave is a verb and a point particle is
a nothing it's known as empty space
and you don't need the word empty
because space is nothing
okay uh here we have another fellow and
he says
i thought they claimed that space was a
vacuum not filled with particles
uh no uh you got that one wrong quantum
mechanics and general relativity back to
all of mathematical physics
believes and holds to this day that
space is made of particles and here you
have just three
examples i got from the internet just
very quickly just
go in there and just put the question
there and you'll find it from everywhere
in fact i got one from abc news
uh science news the other one from quora
the first one i can't remember i forgot
to put the reference but it says first
one says perfectly empty space will
always have vacuum energy whatever
energy is okay energy is a concept but
apparently space is filled with this
concept the higgs field and space-time
curvature
okay so i hope that makes sense to you
because
i don't know what they're talking about
what is this energy thingy
okay and what is vacuum made of see if i
can i'm out of focus here
[Music]
okay
i guess i'm back okay what is a vacuum
made of okay and uh how did they answer
they said the universe appears to be a
strange
quantum phone
okay with virtual particles popping in
and out of existence
obeying the laws of quantum mechanics
that's
what the vacuum is just particles that
come in and out of the void
and physicists uh this corner of
physicists are now be becoming convinced
that empty space is in fact not empty at
all
rather it may be a void that is filled
with a kind of ever-changing static a
sea of something that has been described
as cosmic foam virtual particles of
space-time vacuum energy quantum strings
or vacuum fields
strange fields of virtual particles
popping into and out of existence inside
space
so yeah the the vacuum the mathematical
vacuum is is
not a physical object uh
in the sense that it's made out of many
particles and that's not the definition
of of an object but at the same time
they're saying that
space is
made of particles okay and these
particles
become come into our world by separating
between positive and negative
and when they
get together they form a particle which
is neutral i guess
i don't know ask them but yeah they
think uh space is made of particles and
this is more or less what it looks like
this is the notion they have from the
19th century
where the
wave is the waving of the ether
and what is the ether a bunch of
particles that's what it's always been
ether means just that
space is made out of particles and those
particles are vibrating and that
vibration is what they call light
and uh relativists extended that
to the to gravity and so they talk about
gravity waves what is it that's waving
space
space time
the canvas that's what's waving that's
what prevents the earth from flying out
of the solar system
okay but uh very important uh we have to
celebrate rosh hashanah coming up so we
fellow says rabbi there says we
celebrate the anniversary of the
creation of the entire universe
okay
and why do i bring this up well i bring
this up because a lady there who is a
rabbi and she says i don't believe in a
cosmic god
that if you do this this will happen
and she was referring to what's
happening or what happened in new york
the flood
and she's saying that
that's a little bit of a punishment that
god sent us
she doesn't believe this cosmic
god which is in the talmud you know the
pentatonic first five books of the bible
and aaron talks about a cosmic god she
doesn't believe in that god but at the
same time she says we have to pray
i have to pray so that uh
we appease the god
not the gods
plural but the god up there so that he
takes pity on us and uh
gets rid of all that water he threw
around people so happy rosh hashanah to
you and may your god go with you
we'll see you